[Music]
all right let's go to uh david in san
antonio brother what's up david how are
we doing man
hey dr john i'm doing good how about
yourself we're good brother how can i
help man what's up
um so i guess i have a relationship
question um
so i just got married to my girlfriend
in five years uh this past march hey
hold on one second hold on a second yeah
anytime somebody says i guess i have a
relationship issue
or a question usually that means it's
big is this big i'm trying to get my
frame of mind around it
yeah yeah i'd say it's pretty big um
all right let me switch gears here i've
got a team full of
purple wearing t-shirt people staring at
me so let me get my my head screwed on
straight all right so we got a big one
here go for it brother yeah what's up uh
so yeah so we've been together for about
five years and we just got married um
but i just found out uh pretty recently
at the beginning of summer that
uh well so we were both in school and so
i thought um so for like the past three
years she's kind of been pretending to
go to school and kind of being dishonest
about uh
actually going to school and so i kind
of feel a little bit betrayed i guess
okay so she's kind of been
kind of been not going to school and
kind of been dishonest and you feel a
little bit betrayed so let me back out a
little bit
so your girlfriend's told you for three
years she's going to college he's been
lying to you for three years and you are
pissed off and heartbroken is that a
better way to say that
yeah yeah
so how what's she been doing for three
why she's been lying to you what you've
been doing for three years did she think
after y'all got married you wouldn't
find out what was that what was the game
plan here yeah i i i don't know and
that's where i'm having a hard time like
understanding um i know she
she came from like a family i don't know
if this is me like trying to like
re or rationalize it but uh she came
from a family where it's hard to like
share things you're 100 rationalizing it
you don't lie to somebody for three
years about going to college where's she
been going all day she like faking
writing papers and assignments and stuff
yeah that's pretty much what was going
on um and i saw the red flags bro that's
a long term that's a long-term deception
yeah
what red flags did you see
i never heard of that professor she's
like oh no it's cool man just adjunct
like what was happening so she like to
hardly go to school and are like
like
never
yeah and
it was like uh hardly any homework
assignments that kind of thing and i was
like what school are you going to i
would love to go there but yeah so
so you've known to
yeah um
why did you go along with this for three
years
oh well so we have a daughter together
okay um
could care less why did you go along
with this for three years
i i don't know
what made you all of a sudden decide to
care about this
well i i i cared the whole time
i just chose to trust her
she was pretty good at hiding i guess
but you've known something was off for a
long time though right
right yeah
so how did you find out
i'm fascinated by this three years man
that's a long game in three years it's
not like
she was cheating on you with somebody
else for three years
and she could just break that off
at the end of year four
they give you this dope thing called a
bachelor's degree
and so it's like this had this had like
an expiration date on it this scam she
was running
right and that's kind of
like i that's kind of what i had in the
back of my head i was like how are you
going to do this part like kind of uh
and sure enough when that time came
around so in may
uh when she was supposed to graduate um
that's when she finally came queen and
that was two months after we got married
so she dude she played the graduation
car like yeah i can't wait to graduate
in may all that
um
kind of uh so there's a there's a couple
there's a couple other things that um
she was making it sound so she's in the
military and she was making it sound
like she wouldn't be able to go to the
graduation because she would get
deployed or like she would get uh
something about going to training or
something like that sure so
yeah
so how can i help man what's your
question
well so
i like
i do want to
like i don't want to just
like you know end our relationship like
i want to work through it but i'm having
trouble like from
for myself i guess just
getting like
getting over that hurt i guess
yeah so
um
let me back out what else has she lied
to you about
um
to me like
nothing
not i like nothing big like that she has
she has what else
i mean
they were
like she lied to
like her mom pretty much the whole time
she grew up
and i knew about those lies
as far as why she's told me i don't like
i don't really think there's
very many
so that's the problem
is when you play a three-year con on
somebody that you're marrying
even to the point that you are
pretending that you're graduating i mean
this didn't have an end to it and so
what i'm trying to show walk you through
is this isn't a normal lie
right this didn't have a this wasn't
just gonna
turn into a mist and hopefully be in the
past right and this isn't a matter of
you all met at some bar somewhere and
she told you she was in the fbi and
at some point she had to just come clean
right this isn't like that
this is
a level of deception that feels
pathological to me
yeah
does that make sense yeah and that's
kind of
like this is a strong idea yeah all
lying's a problem
but that this is one that felt so long
game and so calculated and the
calculation was so absurd
this isn't it's it's a level of
deception that is feels clinical to me
that's why i ask you this is a this is a
an mo when somebody does this
yeah right and so you mentioned she lies
to her mom all the time probably about
benign stupid stuff right
yeah yeah for no reason
and so if i'm you i'm questioning
everything
who have you dated who have you been
with are you even in the military is
this my kid is this i would i would
question everything
which then makes it really hard right to
just go grab tacos one night right
yeah
so when you found out about this
was there what was the response was it
like i know i'm so sorry let's just go
out to dinner i mean what was the
response was it a meltdown
uh from from me or like my response to
her both well i mean
um
yeah it was
it was pretty it was pretty rough it was
a rough couple weeks and i think
like i tried to work through it um and
that made me like it took a strain on
like my relationships with like my
daughter with her with my mom i was
getting like i didn't like who i was
becoming okay or i was just
kind of taking it out in the wrong
places you know yep
and here's the thing in all this you got
hurt and you got buzzed bad but you
can't turn into an idiot over this
right you still got to retain
dignity and respectability you got to
treat her with respect even though she
has absolutely not treated you with
dignity
you've still got to take the high road
is that right right yeah that's i guess
i'm having trouble with that
that's a choice brother that is separate
and apart you're hurt and you're hurt
bad and you should be
and you just man you double down on a
woman you've known for five years and
you didn't know her
everything about everything that rug has
been pulled out on you right i get that
everything has been shaking like a snow
globe in your world
and that's it's heartbreaking man
not to mention are you in the military
too
uh no i'm not okay but do you run with
that crew
do you all have any connections together
uh no so i just i graduated pretty
recently like a year ago and i started
working during the whole coveted season
okay five yeah okay
i was gonna say the added stress on top
of what's happening with military right
now it's tough it's a tough season yeah
yeah yeah and that stuff's gonna make
its way how old's your daughter
oh she's three and a half okay so you
got a three and a half year old which is
chaos for any all that to say
yeah i need you to promise me
you're gonna treat your daughter with
dignity and respect you're gonna treat
your wife with respect regardless of if
this marriage doesn't work out you're
still gonna be a person in character
will you make that commitment
yeah good
thank you
we need you your daughter needs you your
community needs you don't take this out
on your mom don't take this out on a
little girl
now i know it's easier said than done i
know that do you have some guys in your
life that are trustworthy
that are aren't idiots and that you can
call
and um they'll come over
yeah i think so okay you gotta let them
in and not in a whining about your wife
kind of way but say hey dude everything
i or the whole sidewalk i walk on has
been blown up
so here's the situation in your marriage
dude um
has your wife given you the hole i
promise this is the only thing and i
don't know what happened and it just got
too big and i couldn't do it i'm so
sorry but let's just move on is that
what you got
yeah pretty much
i think when i live
like
like i think whenever it first started
or at least from what she told me she
said like
she was planning on like
uh re-enrolling in the school and then
um and then like just month after month
went by and then it just never happened
and she just kept it going and then it
just
like she couldn't do it anymore she
couldn't keep it going anymore well
yeah but
and
like she couldn't keep it going anymore
because she was supposed to graduate
supposed to end right
all right so do you want to stay married
to her
i do yeah okay
here's what's got to happen asap
number one you've got to recognize that
y'all are gonna have to
pull apart what you all have and rebuild
something completely new
and
i am hopeful and optimistic that there's
not other boyfriends there hasn't been
other deception that she's been who she
says she is except for this one thing i
don't think that's the case but i hope
so
and then there's gonna have to be
some sort of marriage counseling
like starting tomorrow
um she's actually so she's at basic
training right now um so haven't i when
did she get out
uh probably another month or so okay so
what you've got is a month to go see
somebody and get your head squared away
because you're hurting right
right so i want you to start today make
a call today there is a bajillion great
counselors in san antonio you can go to
betterhelp.com get a discount on
internet counseling right you can see
somebody on your on your computer at
your house
i don't care what you got to do but you
got to go see somebody say i just had
the rug pulled out from under me and i
need to know what to do next
i got a three-year-old little girl here
i've got a woman that i love but someone
who has lied to me systemically and
pathologically for three years and what
that person will do is help you work
through your anger and your frustration
and your pissed off and your fear and
all those things and then give you some
some next steps
and the next steps are gonna have to be
a
there will never be lying in this home
ever again
not over what's for dinner not over what
did you have for lunch not over big
things little things this would be a
truth-telling home and there may have to
be some practice on that your wife may
have to practice that because
i don't think she's ever told the truth
and she may have a lot of personal work
to do too right right yeah
but you've got a month head start on
this and that's really remarkable
because you don't like who you've become
too right
yeah and
ever since like she kind of
uh went to basic training i've kind of
been realizing like
like i was like in this
i don't know just cycle that was just
never ending and
i've kind of gotten a chance to be
myself again i don't know does that make
sense absolutely
absolutely that's why i'm convinced
brother and i don't mean to be negative
debbie downer here i'm convinced there's
other things and i'm convinced that you
know there's other things you don't want
to face it
and whether those other things are
you've just completely shifted who you
are to try to make this weird
relationship happen because you have a
beautiful little girl and you do love
this woman
and you finally got to breathe for the
first time in a month and you've been
able to go
i can't ignore this stuff anymore
on top of the big blowup that's my guess
i may be way out to lunch man and maybe
i'm putting dark seeds in your head i
don't mean to be doing that
something else is here and i think you
know that
but i do appreciate the one important
thing you said
i'm just looping and looping and i gotta
do something different yes yes
so glad you called today you reach out
to a counselor in your area or today you
reach out to a mentor and say i gotta
tell you everything
today you get with somebody that you
trust and you say i'm gonna tell you
everything because i don't know what to
do next
and it's gonna start with you getting
back taking care of your body and your
head and your mind and your daughter and
calling your mom and saying i'm so sorry
i did not like who i become i'm gonna be
different and you're gonna get some
tools
that call starts today and then david
y'all got a long road of rebuild ahead
of you can it happen absolutely
absolutely
this is gonna be hard yep is she gonna
have to be all all in yep she is
you have to rebuild a lot of trust it's
gonna take a long time
is it gonna be worth it i think so i
think she's worth it if you think she's
worth it
your daughter's especially worth it
but you can't brush over this can't come
back from basically like oh it's all
cool it's cool it's good not gonna be
how it works
you have to excavate everything and
rebuild it all
you got this david make the call today